[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna deck your halls bub we have a
very rotten list of holiday duds that
somehow fills us with christmas joy now
just because the film is rotten doesn't
mean it doesn't come with plenty of
christmas cheer or at least enough
one-liners touching scenes or outright
weirdness for it to win our affections
at this time of year so this christmas
for the first time ever we at ron
tomatoes are spreading the love we're
giving you an expanded list of the best
christmas movies ever but these movies
happen to fall on the rotten end of the
tomato meter their movies critics mostly
dismissed but that are still worth your
yuletide time so let's count down the
most rotten christmas movies we love
[Music]
starting with number 10 a bad mom's
christmas
this 2017 sequel celebrates father
christmas by doubling the number of moms
in the first film bad moms mila kunis
kristen bell and katherine hahn butt
heads with their own mothers in a comedy
that doesn't aspire to much more than a
chance for these talented actresses to
pass on a little christmas cheer in
chaos and that they do starring mila
kunis kristen bell catherine hahn and
directed by john lucas and scott moore
critics say featuring twice the moms but
roughly half the laughs a bad mom's
christmas is a slap dash holiday sequel
that falls short of the original with a
disappointing dearth of good cheer you
came over to the house last week
i heard you and daddy in the bedroom and
you kept screaming at him
oh
yeah no honey those were
those were happy screams they didn't
sound happy
and then you punched the wall and yelled
the f part
okay i i um
yeah i don't i don't really recall doing
that so yeah you did you were like oh my
god just like that
oh my god okay all right
um
here's the thing yeah your dad and i
were just playing a fun little grown-up
game you played the game seven times
six and a half but who's counting here's
the thing let's just not
let's just not talk about this cool cool
high five got it awesome
number nine home alone two lost in new
york
there's something charmingly old school
about kevin mcallister's second
adventure he travels to new york by
mistake thanks to airport security
regulations enjoys a new york city that
feels bygone for some vague nostalgic
reason but if remembering christmases of
yesteryear isn't enough for you home
alone 2 is worth it if only because it's
a hoot to see young kevin inflict a
possibly fatal amount of damage to the
hapless wet bandits once again starring
macaulay culkin joe pesci daniel stern
and directed by chris columbus critics
say a change of venue and more
sentimentality and violence can't
obscure the fact that home alone 2 lost
in new york is a less inspired facsimile
of its predecessor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
number eight earnest saves christmas
now you've got to appreciate a movie
that gives the whole plot away in the
title one of the earliest earnest films
ernest saves christmas sees ernest
helping santa claus as he seeks his
replacement it's kind of a proto santa
claus in a weird way starring jim varney
oliver clark noelle parker and directed
by john r cherry iii richard corliss
from time magazine says only marginally
insufferable the earnest movie is a big
screen example of the tv sitcom tendency
to go broad and sappy with a token
yuletide show each december superior
talent incorporated marty brock is my
second born son without a sliver of
gratitude who wouldn't even pick up his
own mother at the airport
i'm only glad his father never lived to
see the day when his son would treat his
own mother this way me a lonely old
woman forced to cope in a world of
indifference hold on just a minute where
is he where is martin i need him to help
me with my will having walked from the
airport i'll be dead soon i don't know
what to do he's with a client that's
life for you
you have two sons one good one bad
and wouldn't you know it with my luck
the good one dies but mrs brock i'm sure
he didn't know you were coming don't
side with him honey there's no future in
it just tell me where he is
number seven silent night deadly night
now it doesn't take a lot of work to
make the santa claus fable horrifying so
silent night deadly night takes the next
logical step and makes an axe murderer
out of him there are some depictions of
mental health in this movie that deserve
big lumps of coal but if you're willing
to just accept silent night deadly night
as a seasonally appropriate 80 slasher
you won't be disappointed starring
robert brian wilson lilgann chavin
gilmer mccormick and directed by charles
e cellier jr kat hughes from thn says as
a modern audience it's hard to see these
deaths as anything but silly but there
is at least still a fun factor that
keeps a viewer watching
[Music]
it was the night before christmas
and all through the house
[Music]
another creature was stirring
[Music]
not even a mouse
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
number six almost christmas
the worst thing almost christmas has
going for it is also the best thing it's
so familiar it's about a big family
coming together for the holidays and
they all have their own personal drama
and relationships but also there's a lot
of love and more than a few laughs now
we've seen this movie before but we keep
seeing it because it works like milk and
cookies for santa comedy dramas like
almost christmas and the yuletide are a
natural comforting fit starring danny
glover gabrielle union monique and
directed by david e talbert critics say
while far from the worst holiday dramedy
audiences could hope for almost
christmas isn't distinctive enough to
prompt a visit to the theater or annual
yuletide viewings i got this uncle
lonnie got this for you okay
uncle lonnie said he would do it
oh
go get out oh
i got a little buzz on my finger that's
how whoa does uncle honey know what he's
doing
no
no
no
no he actually got it
that's what it's all about
[Music]
good job
you actually i did not let the grinches
ruin christmas for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you get that i just posted it good
i'll tell cheryl do not do [ __ ] okay
number five the holiday
now it's fair to say that the holiday is
what would be if it only focused on two
couples instead of like 25. cameron diaz
and kate winslet stars two women who
swap homes for the holidays and fall in
love with jude law and jack black
respectively is the holiday a little
predictable sure but in that special way
that's warm and reassuring it's like the
christmas rom-com equivalent of
chestnuts roasting on an open fire
starring cameron diaz kate winslet jude
law and directed by nancy meyers critics
say while it's certainly sweet and even
somewhat touching the holiday is so
thoroughly predictable that audiences
may end up opting for an early checkout
time iris hi it's amanda how are you
how's it going everything's going great
how are you oh i'm loving it listen can
you hold for a sec my brother's on the
other line graham yes you said you met
yes we did meet how is he fine i think
can you just hold on for a sec sure okay
hi sorry that was amanda how'd she sound
how's she doing she just asked me how
you are and what did you say i asked her
to hold can i call you back
i can hold while you speak to her really
find out how she is
okay
my brother wants to know how you are can
you tell him that i'm good and that i'm
just taking charlie for a walk in the
village um what's he been up to did he
say
i'm not sure do you want me to ask him
uh sure
okay
how old please
i can't believe that you have had sex
with the woman staying in my house
he told you that
oh my god oh my god oh my god i thought
i was talking to graham could you just
hold please i'm
terribly sorry
i can't believe you've had sex with
amanda the one thing she asked me was
are there any men in your town and i
assured her that they were not and then
you meet her and immediately get into
her knickers
still me
number four how the grinch stole
christmas
no not the classic animated special
featuring frankenstein's monster himself
boris karloff as the narrator that
holiday gem sits at a hundred percent on
the tomato meter this jim carrey vehicle
directed by ron howard translates dr
seuss's whimsical illustrations into
live action and the results aren't
particularly good for goodness sake but
while the dr seuss meets tim burton's
nightmares aesthetic is a bit unsettling
the comedy holds up especially in a
scene where the grinch's own echo shouts
you're an idiot at him starring jim
carrey taylor momsen christine baranski
and directed by ron howard critics say
jim carrey shines as the grinch
unfortunately it's not enough to save
this movie you'd be better off watching
the tv cartoon excuse me
the grinch had been caught by this tiny
hoo daughter who got out of bed for a
cup of cold water santa claus
what are you doing with our tree
but you know that old grinch was so
smart and so slick
he thought up a lie
and he thought it up quick
my sweet little dog the fake santa claus
lied there's a light on this tree
that won't
fight on one side
so i'm taking it home to my worst oh my
god
or i mean
presents
number three the family stone
imagine if the worst blowout your family
had over a holiday meal was a movie and
also kind of charming and cathartic
rather than stressful that is the family
stone which stars the great diane keaton
as a forceful matriarch and sarah
jessica parker as a potential future
daughter-in-law rachel mcadams plays
kind of a regina george in sweatpants
and almost seals the show and oh almost
forgot don't forget to bring tissues
starring dermot mulroney sarah jessica
parker diane keaton and directed by
thomas bazucha critics say this family
holiday dramedy features fine
performances but awkward shifts of tone
there it is
okay everett
look i i just want you to know that
oh my god no no it's all right
let's just get this off
[Music]
what's so great about you guys nothing
we're just it's just that we're all
we've
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boy
number two the polar express
robert zemeckis take on the classic
christmas children's book was extremely
ambitious only problem was that motion
capture technology wasn't quite there
yet in 2004 so cgi tom hanks and company
ride the titular train straight through
the uncanny valley now you can't help
but appreciate what zemeckis was trying
to do and there's a very smart christmas
story underneath the eerily smooth
textures in fact there's a case to be
made that the uncanny look of the movie
only adds to the surreal holiday magic
that propels this mighty's train's
engines a case but not an open and shut
one starring tom hanks michael jeter
peter scolari and directed by robert
zemeckis critics say though the movie is
visually stunning overall the animation
for the human characters isn't lifelike
enough and the story is padded
right
[Music]
is
all right keep up with the left
[Music]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the star wars holiday special george
lucas made a habit of going back to
update or change parts of the star wars
films he didn't like for new special
editions but the one thing he can't do
is erase this 1978 tv special from
history sure there was a cool cartoon
that introduced boba fett to the far far
away galaxy but the actors all look
miserable large swaths of the dialogue
are incomprehensible wookie speak and at
one point chewbacca's grandpa gets
noticeably horny if you haven't seen it
well it's actually incredibly hard to
find but you can watch a portion of the
animation from the special called the
story of the faithful wookie on disney
plus so at least we have that to enjoy
starring mark hamill harrison ford
carrie fisher and directed by steven d
binder gail williams from the hollywood
reporter says if the prospect of a
two-hour star wars holiday special
conjured up visions of may the force be
with you repeated ad nauseam in your
head this show on cbs was a welcome
surprise marla it's so good to see you
happy life day
[Music]
she says it may be a happy life day for
you but personally she's seen happier
ones
i i don't want to type the channels
so could you do me a favor and send
either chewbacca or han solo to the
screen please
[Applause]
she says that she would like to grant
your request but is quite unable to do
so
you mean they haven't arrived yet
she says there has been no contact
yes i think i understand her message
that imperial patrol must be giving them
more trouble than we bargained for
mala are you alone
[Applause]
if you would permit me
no she says she is not alone she's with
a friend
four christmases
four christmases understands that the
holidays can be rough especially if
you're dealing with multiple families
who may or may not all like each other
and or you and your partner this 2008
film which has developed a following
over the past decade adds some hilarious
big name actors to that reality in order
to create a movie experience that's a
relatable escape look out for a very
funny turn by katie mixon who would go
on to star in american housewife
starring vince vaughn rhys witherspoon
robert duvall and directed by seth
gordon critics say despite a strong cast
this sour holiday comedy suffers from a
hackneyed script
what xbox
this is awesome top shelf for you pal
it's got the triple core processor
wireless controller's the whole deal
there was a 10 spending cap
how in the hell did you find an xbox for
under ten dollars looks like somebody's
trying to show off how much money he
makes yeah well maybe someone's family
didn't tell him that there was a ten
dollar spending cap or maybe if you came
home more than once a decade you know
crap like that guys can we try to stay
positive here what's the problem we're
just trying to give some gifts to some
children it's christmas let's keep the
momentum going here okay the next gift
is to cody and this is from your dad
okay i'm sure this is a good gift too
okay
dig in there tear it up
a flashlight
that's it
well you love me daddy okay okay uh uh
honestly i think it's my fault i didn't
know that there was a ten dollar
spending cap well my gift from sarah
claus better be straight cool i have a
feeling that your gift from santa's
gonna probably ring in right around ten
dollars too why is santa claus cheap
like my daddy no santa is dead
yeah just close your head and ride
santa
jingle all the way
jingle all the way is not just an
unfairly maligned christmas movie it's
also a pretty good power rangers movie
in disguise go with me here turbo man is
a hero for our time as are dads like
howard langston and myron larabee who in
the true spirit of christmas will brave
crowded malls to make sure their kids
get the perfect present under the tree
on christmas morning starring arnold
schwarzenegger sinbad phil hartman and
directed by brian lavonne critics say
arnold schwarzenegger tries his best but
jingle all the way suffers from an
uneven tone shifting wildly from a
would-be satire on materialism to an
antic slapstick yuckfest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
baby
[Music]
hey lady
hey hold it wait
wait ladies
and finally number one the santa claus
2. the santa claus 2 is a charming
second reminder to always read the fine
print and one that's just five percent
shy of freshness on the tomato meter now
it's fun to see tim allen as a more
confident santa claus in his second
go-around and the film operates in a
neat space thematically everything is
fantastical and christmasy while also
being grounded with talk of contracts
parenting and finding love after divorce
i mean we might as well call it
christmas magic realism starring tim
allen elizabeth mitchell david crumholtz
and directed by michael lembeck critics
say though it's harmless as family
entertainment and has moments of charm
the santa claus 2 is also predictable
and forgettable
[Music]
we have a partridge and a pear tree
you take us to elk com1 and let's wait
for silent running look alive everybody
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i lost it well friends that about does
it for us be sure to stay tuned to the
rotten tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you